one man is dead tonight after a shooting
at a nightclub this happened early this
morning near fremont and eastern bianca
holman has the story
we know there was some altercation
inside the nightclub that was
a verbal altercation that verbal
altercation the two males exited once
that fight spilled out into club 2100
parking lot police say multiple people
called 9-1-1 police received information
about a shooting as officers arrived
shortly after 4 20 a.m they found two
hispanic men suffering from gunshot
wounds both were taken to umc where one
died and the second is expected to
survive what we have learned at this
point is this suspect is also believed
the hispanic male who was last seen
leaving southbound on foot
in the parking lot investigators say a
witness was able to describe parts of
the shooting right now police only know
about one gun involved that could be the
suspects police found a bullet in a
vehicle hit by gunfire at the motel
across the street they will continue to
interview witnesses and look at
surveillance video from the club and
surrounding cameras bianca holman live
local now
if you were at that nightclub when this
happened police are asking you to reach
out to metro homicide or crime stoppers
the number on your screen there to
remain anonymous